[Música]
les doy la bienvenida a un nuevo
episodio de boleto de vuelta que en esta
ocasión nos lleva a angola país africano
que vivió una larga brutal y mortífera
guerra civil durante 27 años comenzó con
la salida del poder colonial portugués
en 1975 dejando que los movimientos
independentistas se enfrentarán entre sí
y en plena guerra fría angola se
convierte en un campo de batalla de un
lado estaba el movimiento popular de
liberación de angola o m pelea de
agostinho neto apoyado por la unión
soviética y cuba y por el otro estaba la
unión nacional para la independencia
total de angola conocido comunidad de
jonas savimbi que contaba con el apoyo
de sudáfrica eeuu y gran bretaña al
comienzo de la guerra fue el mp leal que
dominó el campo tomando el control de la
capital y dirigiendo el gobierno de
facto pero a mediados de la década de
1980 la lucha se intensificó
especialmente en el municipio de kuito
kuanavale en 1988 donde hubo casi 10.000
muertos y una victoria reivindicada por
ambos bandos luego habría un alto el
fuego que se mantendría hasta 1992 y
elecciones supervisadas por la onu
el mp le hagan una votación pero jonas
savimbi este anuncio fraude y se reanuda
en la ducha que acabaría solo diez años
después con la muerte de sabin big
asesinado por las tropas gubernamentales
en 2002 es el fin de la guerra pero no
del sufrimiento de los angoleños el
conflicto dejó casi un millón de muertos
4 millones de desplazados y un país en
ruinas el 60% de los angoleños no tenía
acceso al agua potable el 30 por ciento
de los niños moría antes de los 5 años
20 años después se ha recuperado el país
siguen presentes las huellas de esta
guerra civil
es un monumento que no atrae a mucha
gente pero que simboliza uno de los
mayores puntos de inflexión en la
historia de angola dos manos juntas
dirigidas hacia el cielo con una paloma
en el centro desplegando sus alas
estamos en luena capital de la provincia
de mexico fue aquí el 4 de abril de 2002
cuando la unita y el mp le pusieron fin
a 27 años de guerra civil con la firma
de un acuerdo de paz por cacau y era
teniente de las fuerzas armadas para la
liberación de angola el brazo armado de
unita recuerda el día en que se enteró
de la muerte de jonás savimbi en aquel
momento
en aquella época no teníamos televisión
solo vimos que la gente de aquí de
moxico empezaba a alegrarse hacía ruido
gritaba y pregunte qué pasaba
me dijeron yo sabía que la guerra iba a
terminar así porque él mismo lo había
dicho estamos entrando en un punto de
inflexión mucha gente morirá bajo las
balas otros morirán de hambre y los
demás serán capturados así que cuando vi
que había llegado ese momento me acordé
de lo que dijo webb dice la palabra que
le desea
después de la guerra al igual que
decenas de miles de combatientes en todo
el país dorca se integró en el ejército
nacional
luego se desmovilizó y se retiró hoy en
día vive en esta modesta casa con una de
sus hijas y sus cuatro nietos ahora
lleva una vida tranquila
aquel momento era muy difícil
en aquella época era muy difícil había
niños que sufrían niños que morían yo
era una mujer activa durante la tierra
pescaba para alimentar a mis hijos para
que no murieran esta vida que llevábamos
era muy difícil de mí pero ya se acabó
hoy voy al campo trabajo un poco y les
traigo el sustento a mis hijos otra vida
actual se ha convertido en algo normal
porque estamos en paz ya la vida hoy en
día está un poco normal y porque estamos
en paz una ley aprobada en 2012
garantiza derechos sociales y económicos
a todos los ex soldados con una pensión
básica de 23.000 ones us es decir 50
euros sin embargo 20 años después el
estado aún no ha terminado de hacer el
censo de sus veteranos en luena los
antiguos miembros del mp y de la unita
no se frecuentan mucho pero unen sus
voces para reclamar los mismos derechos
muchas mujeres en particular fueron
movilizadas durante la guerra pero nunca
se ha reconocido su historia de lucha
y mi marido me dejó porque no trabajaba
estoy desempleada
pero aquí estoy con mis hijos tengo
cinco hijos y no tengo el apoyo de nadie
y hoy vivo del trabajo en el campo si no
lo hiciera podría estar buscando comida
en la basura
enrique branco lucho por el mp en el
partido en el poder desde 1975
primero se involucró contra los colonos
portugueses y luego contra unite a 34
años al servicio de su país pero ahora
dice que lo han abandonado
cuando estábamos con agostinho neto nos
decía cuando angola sea independiente no
pagarás el alquiler de las casas no
pagarás el agua hasta ahora nadie ha
cumplido estas promesas a los veteranos
nos tratan como si fuéramos basura nos
pisotean no se acuerdan de que hoy si
tienen lo que tienen si han podido ser
ministros o lo que sea es gracias a los
veranos se les olvidó por completo venir
gracias bastante pues con patentes de un
hembra veinte años después en la guerra
sigue profundamente arraigada en la
memoria del pueblo angoleño a 500
kilómetros de luena huambo era el
bastión de un ita y jonás savings es una
de las ciudades que más sufrió durante
los combates la casa blanca la casa del
antiguo líder
por las bombas del mp l tras las
disputadas elecciones de 1992 sigue
siendo testigo de huambo fico
huambo quedó destrozada casi por
completo muchas casas han sido
destruidas como está ese era el primer
piso pero todo es el trabajo más duro
estaca para paz hasta la fecha no se ha
hecho ningún esfuerzo para reconstruir
la casa de jonás savimbi la figura del
hombre apodado el gallo negro sigue
siendo controvertida en angola su cuerpo
no fue enterrado sino hasta 2019 tras 17
años de negociaciones entre el gobierno
y su familia hoy unita ve esta casa como
un símbolo de la guerra sin embargo para
este sociólogo estas ruinas son una
herida abierta para el país
hemos estado luchando por nuestros
derechos durante 20 años
no hay ninguna razón para que las cosas
sean así al reconstruir esta casa
estamos mostrando nuestro odio mutuo
creo que eso es lo que hay que superar
creo que hay otras formas de mantener
esta casa como símbolo de la guerra
tomar fotos hacer películas y ponerlo
todo en un museo
situada a unos cientos de metros de la
casa branca huambo muestras dos polos
opuestos por un lado el centro de la
ciudad ha sido reconstruido casi por
completo con sus casas renovadas aceras
empedradas y elegantes jardines pero en
los distritos periféricos varios
edificios siguen siendo testigos de la
brutalidad de los combates un poco más
allá el parque industrial antes de la
guerra albergaba unas diez fábricas
todas éstas fueron destruidas y nunca
reanudaron su actividad como esta
antigua fábrica de techos
después de la guerra deberíamos haber
puesto en marcha grandes políticas
públicas o de privatizaciones
la reconstrucción es un todo todo debe
ir junto a agricultura ganadería
industrialización a
la reconstrucción se limita a construir
casas para mí nuestra construcción así
que en pocas palabras cuando no se ha
reconstruido
en una única palabra
one boom no es tarde construir mientras
ambos sigue luchando por reconstruirse
sus habitantes intentan vivir con las
cicatrices de la guerra celestino elías
es uno de los 80 mil angoleños que han
perdido un miembro a causa de una mina
antipersonal tenía dos años
hoy es un futbolista amputado campeón
del mundo y guarda con orgullo sus
medallas y trofeos
aquí
este es el trofeo de 2019 del campeonato
africano de benguela y está la medalla
de 2018 cuando me coronaron como mejor
jugador del mundo
nacido en una familia modesta a
celestino no recibió ninguna atención
médica durante su infancia descubrió el
fútbol a los 8 años cuando su padre lo
inscribió en el club de su pueblo a
pesar de su discapacidad
cuando vi a los otros jugadores yo
también quería jugar pero ellos no
querían cuando entré en la cancha estaba
caminando sobre mis muletas
y les dije que pararán y me dejaran
jugar
y entonces me inscribí en el club de
huambo empecé a entrenar aquí con otros
discapacitados y me hagan tengo un
mandato
en la actualidad celestino es defensa
del equipo paralímpico nacional pero
sigue entrenando cinco veces por semana
en huambo
[Música]
en todo el país hay ahora docenas de
equipos deportivos de amputados
importante es importante promover el
deporte entre las personas con
discapacidad porque el deporte es
probablemente la forma más fácil de
integrarlas en la sociedad si
conseguimos integrar a estas personas en
la sociedad si realmente se sientan
cómodas entonces si nos habremos
beneficiado de los 20 años de paz que
hemos tenido
sin embargo esta integración es todavía
muy limitada en angola la inmensa
mayoría de las personas con
discapacidades viven sin recursos y sin
apoyo estatal
me gustaría que el gobierno hiciera más
para ayudar a las personas con
discapacidad
creo que como personas discapacitadas
tenemos mucho que dar al país
yo por ejemplo fui ayudante de cátedra
trabajo en segundo de primaria pero
hasta ahora no hay oportunidades de
trabajo
20 años después del final de la guerra
civil angola sigue luchando por pasar
página sin embargo el país experimentó
un auge económico en la década del 2000
gracias a la subida de los precios el
petróleo que representa el 70 por ciento
de los ingresos del estado la capital
luanda es testigo de ello con sus
rascacielos y sus renovados muelles
proyecta la imagen de una angola
próspera y moderna pero detrás de esa
bonita imagen la mitad de la población
sigue viviendo con menos de dos dólares
al día para el mp el ganador de la
guerra civil y en el poder desde hace
casi medio siglo el balance de los
últimos 20 años es sin embargo positivo
un país se construye con el tiempo
especialmente en un país como el nuestro
que aún carece de la estabilidad
necesaria y en el que todavía se sienten
los efectos de la guerra lo curioso es
que los que más se quejan son los que
han destruido al país pero nosotros que
tenemos la obligación de reconstruir y
mejorar somos plenamente conscientes de
que ya hemos hecho mucho aunque todavía
haya muchos problemas sin resolver por
robert elegido hace cinco años el
presidente joão lourenço ha hecho de la
lucha contra la corrupción una prioridad
prometiendo pasar la página de la era de
su predecesor josé eduardo dos santos en
el poder de
1979 a 2017 pero a pesar del creciente
número de casos son llevados ante un
tribunal el país sigue estando entre los
más corruptos y desiguales del mundo
hitler samu su q es uno de los
activistas políticos más conocidos de
angola eligió el hip hop para exigir un
cambio de su país
en parte en sus textos no duda en atacar
directamente al presidente de la
república y anima a los angoleños a
salir a la calle
vivimos en una sociedad en la que la
participación política es escasa y la
gente tiene mucho miedo de expresarse
porque teme las represalias y la
represión del gobierno y encontramos en
el movimiento hip hop una puerta una
ventana para transmitir nuestro mensaje
para hacer pasar al mensaje
hitler es el hijo de lorca la veterana
que conocimos en luena si ella dejó la
política traumatizada por 27 años de
guerra él considera que la paz no solo
es el silencio de las armas desde su
barrio reclama una vida mejor para los
angoleños
no estamos
estamos en el municipio de cacuaco en
los barrios del norte de luanda es un
barrio con índices muy altos de pobreza
delincuencia prostitución y
analfabetismo esta es la puerta de una
casa las aguas residuales pasan por
delante y todo el mundo piensa que es
normal
su compromiso lo llevó a que lo
detuvieran y encarcelaran en varias
oportunidades
[Música]
en 2015 junto con otros 16 activistas
por liderar un grupo de reflexión en
torno al concepto de resistencia no
violenta para mi vivir en paz sería
vivir en una sociedad de justicia no
digo en una sociedad justa pero al menos
con justicia con la separación de los
poderes legislativo ejecutivo y judicial
estoy comprometido al igual que mi madre
se comprometió a luchar por la paz yo me
comprometo a luchar para que el mp le
deje el poder para que haya un cambio de
gobierno en angola y para contribuir al
desarrollo del país
para hitler y sus camaradas 20 años
después del final de la guerra civil
angola sigue luchando por pasar página
mate
llegamos al final de este episodio de
boleto de vuelta a angola recuerde que
si quiere ver este y otros episodios en
español puede visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom hasta pronto